доти доки не будуть декларуватися ті хто
насправді керує країною А це радники
офісу президента це всі ці люди які
сьогодні дають вказівки в тому числі
силовим структурам вони будуть тіньовими
цими сірими кардиналами країни і також
ми хочемо звернутися до тих депутатів
які внесли поправку А ви її
проголосували щодо виведення
здекларування керівників державних
підприємств які сьогодні отримують
зарплату від 400 000 грн до мільйона
гривень на місяць з тендерних комітетів
які сьогодні не будуть декларуватися і
ви їх навіть вивели з конфлікту
інтересів це не нормально тому наша
фракція буде вносити поправки про те що
і радники президента є пожиттєвими
пепами ті хто сьогодні керують
міністерствами керують урядом якого
фактично ліквідували керують парламентом
мають і декларуватися і бути пеппами і
так само мають сьогодні декларуватися
керівники